when this thing reads 30 indicates that
it's a sort of a decent level of Hygiene
basically is clean anything over 30 then
I guess into the danger zone it's just
to get a good reading through up the
swap underneath the mat the smell under
here is appalling in these crevices
there's dirt that's gross
that's gross just snap it let the liquid
go down shake in holy crap no I'm
unconvinced for this place is clean
everything smells is very different for
you to identify the smell but in here it
really stinks so just it's just a smell
from here it stains everywhere and what
scares me is at the fact that the
kitchen took a year to get clean cut
nice but this tone so pretty gross
now pop that in there
I'm sure when this place was cleaned
properly then oh my god Karen it's Karen
in there
Karen just go upstairs please two
seconds please let's go quick come in
I've just done a swab test with the
carpet I told if smell is gross anything
above 30 we're in the danger zone for
unhygenic practices and it's not fit for
customers what do you think the reading
is one hundred a hundred fifty fifty
sixty seventy seventy eight hundred and
three eight hundred and three Oh oops
eight hundred and three oops
Bernie I know 103 wow this is just the
carpet you can't be that bad
we get a lot of bikers bicycles and
hikers you pay $130 to get outta bed and
step on a disgusting stinking carpet
it smells like this crap all over the
floor probably cuz there's crap on the
floor Pablo it could be what does that
mean could be
my first shift here you were in the
bathroom and I think you had an accident
on the floor on the mat I mean yeah
there have been times when I have had
diarrhea but it doesn't happen very
often but no I didn't realize that there
was that problem all day both of you
have been in denial not one of you told
me about the problems not one of you
taking any formal responsibility you're
happy to serve that food to me lunchtime
you're happy to mosey around and piss
around on the walls and paint silly
pictures this is a travesty this is
shocking your staff knows it but you two
are oblivious but the rest of the room
is dusted in clean it is it's not he's
not focus not talking about the room
it's not about the rug it's not about
the food it's about the whole picture
look at the page you're yelling am I not
allowed to yell Sarah because someone
asked you because you're not he's trying
to here to help us stop being in denial
it's not about the rug in this perfectly
dusted thing that this is not gonna make
a difference the whole picture the whole
thing what are you scared of can
admitting well I'm working 16 hours a
day I'm spending every 10 minutes
these are rooms to that I get positive
feedback about oh my god I'm serious a
lot of pause there you go again no you
can't be that too no no I think I am not
sleeping in this dump I'm done
[Music]
you can't leave
I'm not staying in here Ramsay don't go
[Music]